foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
good Monday morning good good Monday
morning
I have my voice back
what do you think about that
fantastic
it's fantastic
[Music]
back
better than ever well it's not a hundred
percent yet but it is getting there it
is getting there and we are here uh
let's see let's get the banner going I
forgot to add the bit there we go we got
the banner going it's Monday morning
it's tough on Mondays how are you all
hello everyone
everyone is here Robin's here Lisa's
here Patty's here and here kalyn's here
everyone is here good morning good
morning good morning welcome to the Tony
Michaels podcast every single weekday
noon Eastern 11th center right here on
YouTube Twitter and twitch we have big
announcements this week
we'll get an interview that we've been
meaning to play for a while we just have
had so many stacked on top of each other
so we'll be announcing that this week as
well we have a great interview that
we're doing on Friday shh it's a big
secret we're recording a big interview
on Friday it's a big secret
I really really really big secret
but
there's a lot in the news this morning a
lot from the weekend
uh we have billboard trending what a
[ __ ] scumbag this guy is says he'll
still vote for Trump
in 2024
after what he said in his book give me a
[ __ ] break
we have the Russian army still advancing
into Ukraine it looks like they're
having trouble in some regions of
Ukraine
but they're um they're having success in
other struggles and others so we we will
follow
that conflict as it goes along Vladimir
Putin seems to be more and more uh
spiraling into delusion
I don't know if you have studied Nazi
Germany in the fall of Nazi Germany
the biggest reason for the fall of Nazi
Germany
was that Hitler
was eaten by his delusion a really
deluded fact that we all see is Vladimir
Putin trying to trick the Ukrainian
people
into thinking they have a safe Corridor
into Russia or Belarus
and the Ukrainian people are like [ __ ]
off
you can [ __ ] off with your your safe
corridors your humanitarian corridors
they know what the hell that is you know
what the hell that means
they know Vladimir Putin they've seen
the destruction
and the war crimes that he's willing to
commit on their people and their country
and he's going to try to convince them
that there's some sort of humanitarian
Olive Branch that he's going to extend
to them only to Russia or Belarus
no humanitarian Corridor somewhere else
only to Russia hmm
of course again the Ukrainian people
tell him to [ __ ] off
they want none of it good morning MJ
MJ's here
so
shall we get started on the shitlist
Roundup I I think Gabe's a little busy
this morning Mayo good morning to you
too Mayo's here
Gabe is a little busy this morning so I
don't I don't know that he'll be joining
us so maybe we should just get straight
into the shitless Roundup
we have a couple bills in the news and
they're both scumbags Bill Barr and Bill
Cosby let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
the shitlist
Roundup part of the D20 Michaels podcast
every single weekday noon Eastern 11
Central right here on YouTube Twitter
twitch again we have big announcements
this week about our show and you guys
may have seen the hints from last week
but we'll have some announcements coming
that's exciting
also
I wanna I wanna say
um Carter's here Debbie's here uh muscle
is here everyone is here
so hello and good morning to everyone
I'm so glad that you guys joined me in
the chat make sure you do the thumbs up
thing and the Subscribe thing all the
you know the the YouTube stuff that I'm
supposed to say
my voice is back well not a hundred
percent probably like 98 99 so but I can
still do the Batman voice if I lose it I
don't think I'll lose my voice today
during the show I don't think I'll lose
my voice I struggle last Friday
and we had a good show we had a good
show it was good content it was good
stuff we talked about good things we had
bonehead of the week
but I struggle with my voice
and I apologize but
but I will say I will say that I learned
my lesson
I learned my lesson from Friday
the only way that I will not be on air
is if I cannot utter a single word
that is the only way I will not be on
air
I will be on air as long as I can muster
up enough
to uh
sort of speaking to the microphone if
you go watch episode 89. that's kind of
crazy today's episode 90.
episode 90. we're so close to 100
episodes
of course it's gotten really fast here
and the reason why is because we're
doing it every single day you know we
used to do the podcast
as of the podcast itself every Wednesday
and then we would do the twitch streams
and we had bonehead of the week we had
all these things going
and then we just combine them all into
one show every single day we put the
shitless Round Up in there we have the
interviews in there
we have Poppins maybe we should get uh
pop back on what do you guys think
there's a lot of legal stuff going on
I'd like to ask popoc about some things
especially um today uh there is a
decision for Bill casby
and
[ __ ] rapist
so we'll we'll see uh we'll dive into
that thread and see what the news is I
don't know exactly what the news is I
heard there is a Supreme Court decision
um that seems like from what I read
lightly before I put him in the uh the
trendy Trends there is that uh that
possibly it's going his way which is not
a good thing for justice
so we will we will see about that
on how well that goes the other thing
too I'd like to I'd like to try to get
this week as we talk about the week is
try to get Rachel bitkoffer on again
I know you guys love Rachel and lover
insights into messaging surely there
will be something this week that we can
talk about messaging
so we got popeck Michael popock if
you're listening out there
and we got Rachel bitkoffer hopefully
we'll get her Rachel if you're listening
there's a few other kind of things that
we're trying to work on to get people on
to talk to them about some Twitter drama
and I don't know if we'll make it happen
or not I've been ghosted by a few uh
people trying to get trying to get them
on the show to talk about Twitter
Twitter drama Twitter drama you guys
have probably seen some Twitter drama
going on
trying to get some folks on to Yap about
it maybe Yellen scream hash it out you
know [ __ ] like that instead of hashing
it out in the comment threads and in DMS
they come on the show I'll let them hash
out their Twitter drama sure why not
we're talking about Twitter we're here
on Twitter we're surfing the Tweety
tweets and attorney Trends anyways why
not add the Twitter trauma I don't know
maybe maybe it'll end up being um the
podcast to end up being like that the
Jerry Springer of Twitter here right you
know like people have Twitter drama so
they come on here and you know hash it
out the uh the Mori
you are not my Mutual I don't know I'm
just you know yapping into the
microphone
we're 11 minutes into the hour let's get
let's get to the trendy Trends and the
Tweety tweets here let's make this a
little bigger so y'all she yells can see
that dude
[Music]
um
you guys know there's a lot of breaking
news in Ukraine with Putin uh this uh
video here Jim Acosta pointed out the
leave us alone you bastard
um this Holocaust Survivor says to Putin
um
uh actually has the uh the video here
from Jim's show Let's uh let's see if we
can watch this here it is definitely
worth watching
the plea from a holocaust Survivor to
tell Putin to [ __ ] off here we go
Ukraine's Holocaust Survivors have been
speaking emotionally about the war
they're now enduring and sending a blunt
message to Vladimir Putin
we want peace we want peace in June 1942
the war started all my relatives on my
mom's side were Jews
Jews
everyone was killed there yes today I am
again
but it is this year
the audio only that is the translation
of that video
Putin I hope you die leave us alone you
bastard is what a Holocaust Survivors
say and Kiev recorded a direct message
to the Russian dictator ordered him to
get the [ __ ]
out of Ukraine
I don't disagree with him he should [ __ ]
off uh okay let's let's keep going down
the timeline here
um this is very interesting uh Boris
Johnson was trending earlier I think
Boris Johnson out
was trending I believe
I I think I think that's it I think
that's it
um but let's let's see
let's see what what um is prompting
Boris Johnson to everyone wanting out
seems that Boris
maybe taking a stand with Putin as
opposed to
the EU
[Music]
welcome to Umbria in the heart of Italy
and we're interested in this mountain
over here you could call it La Montana
de ruse the mountain of the Russians
The Far Side of the Mountain
is owned by the akunen family very close
to Vladimir Putin and there's even
gossip that Putin himself might have an
interest in the mountain
he definitely has an injures in the
mountain the prussians are there if
Russians own it he owns it that's the
whole point
that's the whole point the south side is
owned by evgeny Lebanon
that's his beautiful Palazzo Palazzo
Terra Nova and the regular guest
is Boris Johnson first there's one of
the mayor then his foreign secretary now
you so Morris Johnson went to this
Castle right this Russian's Castle
where Vladimir Putin possibly owned
interest in this Castle or this property
hmm seems kind of suspicious doesn't it
you know the funny part about this whole
thing is that John Sweeney here
this is a post from 2019. look here
October 7th
2019.
so this isn't new stuff
let's go back to the video
it'll be astonished to discover whether
these parties there's a ton of Russian
women beautiful lovelies from Russia and
elsewhere
so Boris goes to bunga bunga parties in
Italy who gives the damn I don't
box and here's the rub MI6 did what
concerned them was not what Boris was
doing but where he was doing it the
Russian mountain I have two sources
who've told me that MI6 was worried that
Boris Johnson when he was foreign
secretary was a security risk
so the MI6
um forces in the UK were were worried
that Boris Johnson was going to be
compromised
my Russian oligarchs this sounds
familiar like this
this sounds familiar doesn't it like how
in the [ __ ] I I guess I guess when you
have
um as he put it uh pretty Russian girls
flocking around the the castle there I
guess maybe that's the attraction to for
some of these men rather be Boris
Johnson or Trump or whoever I'm just
throwing names out there
let's finish and there's another thing
well at least one occasion that we know
about when Boris Johnson came to his
Elite he left his Metropolitan Police
Protection Team back in England
now you don't have to trust me on a word
of this because this story has been
reported by the BBC and the Sunday Times
this summer the newspaper even quoted
the cabinet minister saying that I have
to say that this video is good it's got
good information but it's very odd the
music in the background isn't it
I'm not I'm not knocking on Sweeney here
I'm just saying the music in the
background is a little distracting it
doesn't seem like the the music that
should be in the background I'm just
saying I mean you guys hear it on the
audio version and you guys are seeing
here the the background music is a
little distracting like it's a little
distracting I'm just saying
Boris Johnson because of his private
life was open to Blackmail
then Boris Johnson becomes prime
minister
and silence Falls but the question
stands prime minister to clear the air
will you launch an inquiry to discover
whether there is a security risk inside
number 10. to which
yourself
and there's the closing with me
on the hill okay
um thank you for first for
um having this report and again this is
not big news that Boris Johnson has
possibly been compromised by Vladimir
Putin
uh and today the the trend is is that
people in the UK may want Boris Johnson
out
because he isn't playing ball with the
EU
on some of the sanctions and being tough
on Russia now Christopher has uh some
pictures here that posted he says the
Ukrainian Invasion or excuse me the
Russian invasion of Ukraine
has revealed to the world how crappy and
old Russian conventional military
equipment really is
um that's been sort of a big story
is that this this Russian equipment
hasn't really been all that great
um that's been one of their [ __ ]
setbacks so far with the Ukrainian
people
uh taking over Ukraine is that their
equipment has been [ __ ] and sometimes
their tactics has been [ __ ] and the one
reason why their tactics are [ __ ] is
because
uh Putin has lied to his forces about
the mission that is at hand and because
they've lied to his because he's lied to
his horses with the mission at hand they
think there's a completely different
Mission than what their mission is so
that is not good for morale that not
only is that not good from round that's
not good for
for the way that they want to March into
Ukraine now it appears
that in the north uh the Russians are
still struggling in the south
they're making some advancements
um as I was coming on the air today they
still have not taken the the city of kiv
um they are advancing into the City and
people are trying struggling to leave
their country because civilians are
being killed women children men and it's
uh it's very hard y'all hurry up uh
posted I don't believe Putin is creating
a humanitarian Corridor that's what
they're calling it he is jerking their
chain absolutely he is they're saying
360 civilians have been killed but who
the [ __ ] really knows since every male
over 18 who has previously a civilian is
now military someone has to stop him now
um I agree
um this is getting out of hand and the
more the more we get in this um
this cycle of Putin's delusion what I
mean by that is is is the more you know
the world kind of tiptoes around this
idea that Putin's still a leader because
I I believe that um
as we go along here it's getting less
and less likely that he is the true
leader of Russia just as if
and Nazi Germany Hitler was the leader
of Germany it was all falling apart at
the seams and the reason why is because
Not only was the the Nazi Germany
military the Nazis
um working off delusional orders
but they were happening to pretend that
things did or didn't exist on the
battlefield
um which is very dangerous to their
mission right
you can't uh can't have a mission based
on delusion that's one reason why some
of these Russian troops are so easy to
become prisoners of war or to surrender
to Ukrainian forces some have criticized
Ukraine for for interviewing them and
talking to them
but they're they're treating them like
humans when they do capture them and
they're trying to give them truth well
what I mean by that is Russia and Putin
has lied to these troops has lied to not
just them but their families these
people are completely brainwashed of why
they are there
why they are there
so
um papa bear says Ukraine is getting a
Master Class
and what fighting for democracy is
giving excuse me is giving a master
class of what democracy fighting for
democracy really means [ __ ] Putin yes
um and also [ __ ] the trucker convoys I
don't know if you guys seen that they
are scared of rain
um and I think that's what Papa Bear is
alluding to here is that these uh these
fascists around the world and even in
our country
who think somehow mandates that don't
exist anymore because they successfully
got their bought and paid for Supreme
Court to tear them down exist and
they're bitching about freedom from
something that doesn't it isn't in
effect anymore I don't understand it
you can't make it make sense
um these people are living in delusion
it's the same reason why there are some
Russian forces marching into Ukraine
under one mission
getting there and realizing that that
mission is not a mission at all
it's all [ __ ] Dan says ukrainians
have uh courage and grit that America
used to have their story is inspiring
and should serve as a reminder about
what Fighting For Freedom actually looks
like this is a theme this is a theme
um and and the reason why you were
Ukrainian people have the courage and
Grit
that America used to have is just what
we're talking about
they have a national truth right there's
a national truth
built around it
we
have a large population not
percentage-wise but a large number of
people who aren't adhered are Tethered
to a national truth or a reality for
that matter now Mark Levin is trending
so I said
and we'll get to why Mark live in this
trending probably maybe who knows Mark
Levin is trash good morning that's all
you need to know
um billboard of course is trending I
said why hasn't Bill Barr [ __ ] all the
way off already it's about time he [ __ ]
all the way off not just a little bit
all the way
we'll get to the billboard thing soon
and let's see
this is a gay true socialist training
this morning too uh because it [ __ ] the
bed it is still not got off the ground
he said Trump's social media app true
social is the 140th most popular free
app and Apple's App Store good and he
has a video here I'll show it to you
um
doesn't have any sound I think you
should have put some sound with it
maybe we should make Gabe put some sound
with this
but it shows
uh him scrolling through the numbers
yeah yeah well oh well we might have to
go all the way down to 140. there it is
true social
uh people still cannot get on this app
people can still not log in people are
still waiting on the waiting list
[Music]
uh all to make sure that Devin Nunes
doesn't have a den of a new name's Cal
account I think that's why I think he's
terrified he didn't want to open this
app and because he knows there's going
to be a some iteration of Devin nunes's
cow
[Music]
okay uh I said true social [ __ ] the bed
again and again and again it [ __ ] the
bed just like Grandpa poopy pants
shits himself uh on the humanitarian
Corridor as I said humanitar
humanitarian Corridor Corridor Jesus
humanitarian corridors in quotes
that lead to Russia and Belarus my
[ __ ] ass
these are not humanitarian corridors
this is more this is more [ __ ]
for Vladimir Putin
because as Joe says here Vladimir Putin
is evil and they should treat him as
such
the Ukrainian people should not trust a
single thing
that him or the Russians say or give to
it
let's see what else do we have here oh
this is really speaking of the trucker
Convoy Ron has this video here
oh oh my gosh
oh the cosplay so for all you audio
listeners out there Audio Only listeners
if you're on Spotify or Apple
this guy what appears to be in some kind
of night uniform like a crusader Knight
uniform
uh cosplaying this stuff
Ron says guy guy that's his that's the
title that runs again guy
guy at trucker Convoy I believe it's the
people's Crusade people have to fight
the evil in the world and people have to
band together and fight side
fight on the side of the Lord okay all
right what does the Lord have to do with
the with with
bogged up highways I don't understand
this
I don't understand what the [ __ ] they're
talking about you guys we're gonna see
the Ricky Schroeder video I'm gonna show
that [ __ ] you goddamn right I am
let's listen to this fool first at least
at least this guy gets in the costume
Ricky Schroeder can't even get in the
costume anymore is this a crusade
in the fact that people have to fight
the evil in the world man and the evil
is uh well you're heading down to the
evil in the world and people have to
band together and fight on the side of
the Lord
now God will what does this [ __ ] even
mean
what is this [ __ ] word salad [ __ ]
I have to fight the evil world you know
what the evil is we're going to it what
what
I don't I don't understand where where
are you going where the evil is
like you guys you [ __ ] guys have been
driving all over the country and it and
it's less like the Ottawa trucker you
know they they had this [ __ ] boner
for weeks and weeks about the audio
Ottawa trucker thing in Canada you
remember that [ __ ] the Gibson go
fraud
where they were trying to fraudulently
collect money
and launder money I mean that's the
evidence that it shows the data leak you
guys seen the interview if you haven't
seen the interview we interviewed hi-fi
from radicalized podcast
and he he laid it out from the the
[ __ ] data
and he's still combing to the data as we
speak of the give send go data leak and
we see more reports now
that Gibson go lied about them not
receiving any funds now they're trying
to backtrack which is getting them in a
little bit of trouble
in the in the Canadian Parliament
but besides that
this Convoy in this country in America
this parade of fools right
Caravan of fools there's a John Prine
song
um I don't know if you guys knew who
John Prine is he's a he he passed away
because of covid which is a great
tragedy of of covid to take uh one of
the great folk songwriters of our of our
country and of our time John Prine away
from us
um it took so many
and uh John Prine was one of those
people who passed away from covid in
2020 and I was very sad because I hadn't
seen John Prine in concert I was
supposed to he got sick in 2019. and
then the pandemic happened
I'm a big John Prine fan again he's one
of the great folk songwriters and
singers
um of of our time but John Prine has a
song
called the Caravan of Fools and you guys
have to go see this maybe maybe I'll
I'll tweet the link
um here later
but but John prine's Caravan of fools
reminds me of these idiots but anyways
this is more of a caravan than a convoy
I guess maybe it is a convoy character I
don't know
but they wanted to emulate what happened
in Ottawa right because the government
had to you know break it up and that's
what they want they want the show they
want the they want the political theater
the covet theater as Ron DeSantis said
last week when he when he bullied kids
to take off their mass that they had on
and wasn't hurting him or anyone else
he just didn't want people behind him
his props behind him to have masks on
because he didn't want to catch hell
from the Facebook Ivermectin group
I'm gonna [ __ ]
people like this dumb [ __ ] here in this
costume
and so he didn't want to catch hell from
him
and here's the thing
the Ottawa trucker thing was actually
disturbing Commerce like they were
blocking a fairway
a fair way of Commerce
these people are just
they're driving around in their Trump
trucks with their Trump Flags this isn't
a [ __ ] has anything to do with
mandates there's no that the mandates
are they're done
you bought and paid for your Supreme
Court which did away with any mandates
that our country could possibly place on
you to keep our communities safe and
healthy and by the way by the way
because you [ __ ] idiots spread around
the last variant
and killed off
hundreds of thousands of more people
with the last two variants
and got everyone [ __ ] sick in this
country because you wouldn't [ __ ]
listen
you have made it to where we don't even
need Mass Joe Biden said at the State of
the Union speech and they're not even
they're not listening
he said he said out loud
the tyrannical Joe Biden the guy who's
gonna make you wear masks and brainwash
you with a mask as if that's a thing
he said in front of a microphone and
most people don't have to wear a mask
there isn't the risk now in most places
in America
because a large percentage of the
population is not only vaccinated
but you killed off
a large number of people who weren't
vaccinated and you ended up spreading
around both variants to people who
weren't vaccinated so those who weren't
who didn't die
have some sort of
immunity now
that's that's what the science was gonna
say anyways
now the science also said it was much
easier and much much better for the
community and health of our country and
the safety of our country and to get our
economy back on track quicker it was a
lot more efficient to go get just go get
your [ __ ] vaccine in your booster and
you would have gained the immunity
without having to get sick and destroy
the ability for our economy to get back
on track faster
she didn't listen to that
but now you're in a situation where
there is not covered chaos
they want coveted chaos they want it
don't be assured that's what this
[ __ ] Convoy is about is to stir up
the kovic chaos
because fascists can't take control of
things without chaos like if there is
order well then if it's all in order how
are they going to bang up how are they
going to bang up your Liberty
right I mean how are they going to steal
away your Liberty if if there's order
and everyone around is going like well
what are you bitching about
what do you mean everything's fine
everything's cool
it's all cool no problems
but see they gotta have chaos to
continue this garbage
that's what the whole 2016 election was
about oh my God her emails her emails
it'll be chaos it'll be World War
because of her email
and she has a vagina and vaginas can't
start next start wars you know like
every other War before that was started
with a [ __ ] white ball sack
Wars are not
are not started by women
are way too smart
and way too savvy
to start wars like Vladimir Putin
hmm
or any other war in the last century
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] that
that was the chaos that they would sow
she's corrupt she murdered people all
kinds of [ __ ] lies all kinds of crazy
ass [ __ ]
they did the same thing in the 2020
election Hunter Biden's I mean Jesus
Christ they still can't stop obsessing
they can't stop obsessing about Hunter
Biden's laptop
I don't know how many times we have to
say it
but people are lining up and paying two
thousand dollars to take pictures with
Donald Trump Jr that crackhead there
ain't a goddamn Democrat in this country
that would take two thousand dollars to
take a pit well I shouldn't say it
any most people who vote blue rather
they're Democrats or not just because
they're not fascists probably wouldn't
even take two thousand dollars
to take a picture with Hunter Biden and
Hunter Biden isn't standing in lines to
take pictures or give donations or he's
not at the White House
getting off track here the point of this
whole diatribe here is that they don't
have chaos
with covid and they're trying to create
chaos with covet that's what the whole
Ottawa trucker thing was they shut down
the Fairway they shut down the bridge it
shut down Commerce it caused a lot of
chaos under the guise of covid which
that was a [ __ ] lie
90 of the truckers in Canada were
[ __ ] vaccinated already it didn't
matter it didn't [ __ ] matter
it wasn't gonna matter
but they have to have lies to cause
chaos that's what fascists do to
convince Dum Dums to do dumb things
I mean I'm not saying all the people who
buy into this Q Anon [ __ ] think that
they're fascists they don't know that
Dum Dums do dumb things
and they believe dumb things especially
when people tell them dumb things
and I'm not saying they're not
intelligent I'm not saying they're not
uneducated they're just dum-dums Dum
Dums meaning you know you you're will
sometimes it's a willingness to uncouple
yourself from reality especially if it
doesn't fit your narrative
if it doesn't feel good to you oh the
truth feels so bad to me what am I gonna
do about the truth
so that's where we're at
with this trucker Convoy
and it it went over like a wet fart in a
white thong we've seen the rally from
the from the week before there was one
person there well I mean there was a few
his family was there let's be fair
but then we have this trucker Convoy
over the weekend and they got rained out
they took one lap around DC it started
raining then they tucked tail and run
it's all griffed it's all griffed it's
all in in in the guys to create chaos
so that uh these fascists can grift
money support money so that way they can
continue to grift off chaos
they're really disappointed that this
that
this this code with chaos is coming to
an end they really counted on this chaos
in 2022.
but again it's going over like a wet
fart in a white line let's listen to
what the Crusader here has to say
do a story on descent in the banks here
we're seeing images of trucks and people
people signing trucks
okay never that [ __ ]
thank you Ron for posting this video Ron
keeps a good eye on on this stuff so we
don't have to
do okay
[Music]
um
oh the mark Meadows story Ron's got that
too
I don't know if you guys heard Mark
Metals mine a committed voter fraud
we're 40 minutes into the first hour
I I hesitated to do this Mark Meadows
thing uh in the first hour because I
think I think just this picture alone uh
if you're only listening on audio
you won't see this but they posted a
picture
of the
the trailer home and I believe this is
this is right the house of Mark Meadows
that Mark Meadow's wife rented if you
guys don't know this story
what has happened is Mark Meadows
sold their house
in North Carolina
here's Ron's uh
synopsis of the New Yorker story he said
Mark Meadow's wife rented a property in
North Carolina that was used as their
voter registration address so he could
vote absentee
in the 2020 election so Mark Meadows did
a mail-in ballot
you son of a [ __ ] you fraudulent oh
that's not the fraud oh the actual
mail-in ballot isn't the fraud I see he
may have committed voter fraud by using
the address of a place he never stepped
foot in
apparently Mark Meadow's wife now let's
give credit here to this apparently Mark
Meadow's wife
rented this trailer home
they sold their house in North Carolina
and because of that
they have like a condo or something in
Virginia
where that's where Mark Meadows lived
while he was working in DC
but he wanted to be a North Carolina
resident so he could vote North Carolina
so apparently his wife rented a a mobile
home
now if this really is the mobile home
this is uh
[Laughter]
here's the thing here's the thing Mark
Meadow is supposed to be some kind of
real estate Guru or some [ __ ] right like
that says comeuppance
is he got into real estate he got into
the gate vacation properties or some
[ __ ] in North Carolina
I wonder if this is like where he would
like to Vacation maybe send his
customers to and apparently they didn't
buy this property they rented this
property as their as their
as their residents so that they could
vote
it really is
it really is uh on brand for the
Republicans
to talk about voter fraud and mandolin
ballots and here Mark Meadows is
possibly committing voter fraud by
claiming to be a resident of North
Carolina when he obviously is not
he isn't a resident if you don't live
there you're not a resident
so it seems like Mark Meadows is
commending voter fraud so that he could
vote on a mail-in ballot
which mail-in ballots bad apparently
up until the 2020 elections mail-in
ballots were good for Republicans
because generally their constituents
voted on mail-in ballots
with the pandemic people realize that
mail-in ballots might be a more valid
way of safely voting and discovered well
most States it's not so hard sometimes
and to get a mail-in ballot and that's
when the Republicans realized this is
not a good thing we can't let them have
mail-in ballots easily but Mark Meadows
here he definitely wants a mail-in
ballot very easy he wants it to be very
easy to get a mail-in ballot
for an address that he's never lived at
never step foot in
Prairie on brand
okay let's see
um let's go back to the timeline here
uh oh gay points out uh that uh Russia
is still being hacked on several fronts
by the group Anonymous at this rate I
wouldn't be surprised if Anonymous took
over Russia's defense system with this
message he has a gift here it says shall
we play a game
[Laughter]
um
well since we don't have Gabe on the
show we have Gabe in tweets on the show
uh let's see here is the Ricky Schroeder
video I know you guys have been waiting
for this patiently
patiently been waiting for the Ricky
Schroeder video
what number one
okay Ricky
and again I would have Ricky on the show
absolutely 100 percent
I would now I would the conditions would
be that he couldn't be sitting by a
campfire it kind of creeps me out I
don't know if this guy like I don't know
if he lives out of a
um you know a tent I don't know if he's
like camping that's how he's living I
have no idea
but he really does seem like he sits by
the campfire a lot and he does he can't
buy her videos and they're really
bananas so I don't know if he's like
doing drugs while he's starting to fire
or something getting the fire going
RV's drinking I don't know what's going
on but it's a lot of word salad it's a
lot of Jesus it's a lot of Bible where
the Bible doesn't really have anything
to do with what he's talking about like
what does the Bible have to do with the
price of gasoline what the [ __ ] are you
people talking about
what Jesus Jesus didn't say anything
about the price of fuel
oh [ __ ] these people okay let's let's
listen to what old [ __ ] Ricky here
has to say Jesus Christ this Convoy is
heading up I-15 Salt Lake and across
Southern Wyoming and down through Denver
and um I heard about another dozen
convoys
are uh performed and are moving
and praise God because
this is this has got to be the stand we
make
you're not standing if you're moving
like a convoy isn't a stand
like a convoy isn't a stand right like
the Ottawa Convoy they were standing
they were standing still
you you
moving in a convoy along the highway
which your whole purpose is to shut down
the highway but you're you're you're
[ __ ] moving like you're driving so
you're not shutting down the highway
like you're not shutting down Commerce
and most the trucks most the trucks that
are that are driving well you're just
you're just spending money on that
expensive fuel that you're talking about
with with no Revenue attached to it
which means you're killing your profit
motive for your trucks which apparently
is your claim to fame that your
capitalist and you one of the American
capitalist Society I don't know
they're all twisted around
like they're so uncoupled from reality
and a lot of people were giving uh Ricky
here [ __ ] about his uh his coat where
it's got the tear on the shoulder you
see
um and and it's you know it's a you know
he's got overalls on it's what this
looks like to me
you know and wherever's Ricky's at here
it's apparently cold
he's been by the campfire blast I don't
know
it it
I I mean maybe maybe maybe maybe maybe
he's
uh homeless I don't know I can't tell at
this point I mean it's hard to know
where Ricky's at
let's finish his word salad here
we're not livestock we're not cattle
you know we can't be treated as such
we're free
and purging you know law enforcement and
purging the military
uh that's just the writing on the wall
what they're setting up there
they're setting up to set up we the
people against our own
our own institutions
they don't want to have Patriots in
those institutions that will resist them
so we've got yeah yeah see when you say
Patriots this is this is the problem
here
so he's talking about a lot of different
things I think this guy's got a lot of
different things going through his mind
um he's obviously delusional he can't
express a certain thought or certain
feeling or a certain point
so he's talking about God and convoys
and people moving and then he goes to
law enforcement and Military and these
Patriots are being purged
I think this is uh the mandates thing
that they're talking about where the
military saying no you you have to get
vaccinated that's one place that the
mandates are gonna [ __ ] probably
survive it's a military
because that's how the military's always
worked you you don't choose what you get
vaccinated for in the military they
choose for you whether you like it or
not
like I'm not sure the exact list but I
think it's like 20 some 20 or 30 some
vaccinations that you have to have when
you get into the military and if you
haven't had them they just give them to
you they line you up and they [ __ ]
shoot you in the arm with that vaccine
you don't know what they're giving you
that's what happens
you're in the military now you're going
to go a lot of places around the world
they have to make sure you're vaccinated
from disease and viruses all around the
world not only so you don't get sick and
our military isn't crippled because our
military is [ __ ] sick but so you
don't bring it back here
to other folks in our country are spread
it around
it's what happens
so yeah those mandates are probably
going to live right and maybe that's
what he's talking about here
is the mandates of the military but he's
saying Patriot and I [ __ ] that we we
really
ah these words that they've stolen from
us they've stolen these words
which is [ __ ] ridiculous he means
terrorist is what he means he means
domestic terrorists the domestic
terrorist in our military and our law
enforcement who want to overthrow the
oath that they took
to the Constitution
to get it that they're supposed to
defend
Ricky you dumb [ __ ]
if Ricky had as much sense as he has
logs for his fire he would understand
this
they're not purging these people from
law enforcement or military not purging
them
these people are not following their
oath that they took
and in that form Ricky
you don't have a job I mean it's not
exactly like you not acting for the last
20 years but it's kind of close and
let's continue with this garbled [ __ ]
verbally
and they've got to allow Freedom yeah
for anybody that wants you everybody
that wants it
because until we're all we're not free
until we're all free from this
that includes our kids in uniform
you gotta back off and drop the mandates
so so that's that's the next fight and
the reason why is because all the
mandates have been dropped there never
were mandates in the first place these
weren't mandates there were requirements
in the first place now the military is a
mandate they are going to mandate that
you have it
but that that the other the other
mandates were requirements they were
choices that you were [ __ ] making if
you didn't want to work at a place
because they were requiring the
anti-vaccine you could [ __ ] leave
this is all nonsense
anyways about the word mandate which the
government and the Biden Administration
and anyone else the private sector
should have never called them mandates
their requirements you're required to
have something
just like at some places you work you're
required to have a [ __ ] piss test
they make you piss in a cup
they make you [ __ ] piss in a cup
to work there
right give they make you give them some
of your [ __ ] piss
and they test it
it's a requirement to work some places
some places it's not just like the
vaccine there are requirements at some
places for the vaccine some places there
weren't
it's a thing
because because we're not going to live
like it yeah so unless you're ready to
I guess kill us all see this this is
where it gets really [ __ ] dark and
really weird
and the reason why it gets really dark
and really weird
is because they're projecting this
this is what Ricky is projecting here
this is the delusion that he this is the
fascist illusion that he's spinning in
his head that we are going to kill them
what are you [ __ ] talking about you
have killed yourselves
by not getting vaccinated you killed
hundreds of thousands of people
since the end of last year
because you [ __ ] idiots didn't get
vaccinated and listen to what the
[ __ ] experts were saying
because you continued on this barrage of
misinformation and delusion and led
people to believe that oh what Ricky
Schroeder's saying by the campfire is
true well that must be true
and somehow not getting vaccinated was
the good thing
against to protect yourself against the
coronavirus and it led hundreds to
hundreds of thousands of people who were
unvaccinated as death now there are a
few there are some vaccinated people
that lost their lives even though they
were vaccinated but you look at the
numbers and it is swayed in One
Direction not just with death but
hospitalization for [ __ ] sake
and this [ __ ] that he's talking where
he's saying you just might have to kill
us that's projection folks
that's fascist projecting
because here's how they convince because
he said we're not cattle we're not
livestock
that's also projection they are sheep
they are livestock they are cattle
and they're following their [ __ ]
Shepherd their leader Trump
and the idea isn't really Trump himself
it's trumpism it's fascism in a Maga hat
this make America great again [ __ ]
what he's doing is he's projecting what
they want to do they've said it they've
said it
they were saying it at a turning point
USA when Charlie Kirk was speaking there
was a there was a dumb [ __ ] there saying
when can we kill him when can we kill
him when do we get to shoot him and kill
him
don't don't take it from me go look at
the [ __ ] video I don't have it at
hand but it exists
but that's what Ricky's doing here is
he's projecting their fascism and their
what they want
on us that's why when they say oh the
the
the
the
vaccine's gonna kill you it's gonna kill
you it's designed to kill you
no
it's not it's not designed to kill you
it's not going to kill you
the virus will but they're projecting
it's always a projection when fascist
uh you better change your minds
because we're not going to live as
slaves oh slaves
uh Ricky living underneath the [ __ ]
Bridge as a homeless person are
pretending to whatever you're trying to
whatever cosplay you're doing here if
that's what you're doing is not you not
being a slave dummy you're making a
choice you have a choice either get it
or don't get it we don't I don't give a
[ __ ] at this point I don't care anymore
I really don't give a [ __ ] if you don't
get vaccinated whatever fine you just
you have to live with the consequences
of doing that of making that decision
just like any other [ __ ] decision
that you make like wearing that [ __ ]
jacket that you got
that's a decision that you have to make
and you have to limit the consequences
of people talking about your [ __ ]
screwy ass jacket
to a society that is Godless
so
anyway God bless the convoys that moves
out here and here's where he gets to the
prayer are you guys in Springville Utah
at 8 pm when you get there and then I'm
gonna ride with you guys
and uh
free America
free America from this medical tyranny
and these corrupt leaders
who are bankrupting us and our
children's futures
so
okay that's enough okay but you do you
see how this it sounds like words out it
sounds like a bunch of gobbledygook
right it sounds all kinds of [ __ ] up
and crazy
but this is the delusion that your
neighbors are believing this is the
delusion that your co-workers are
believing
because here here is the truth Ron
posted it this is the people's Convoy in
DC this is rsbn's coverage of it this is
their coverage this is supposed to be
the greatest coverage that they're
supposed to get the real news not the
fake news
and this is the coverage listen to this
report the American truckers yeah there
is some rain coming through and I know
that the people's Convoy asked a lot of
people to return home to start packing
up stuff not to move oh they might melt
the Convoy might melt I'm melting I'm
melting rain really you ran because of
rain
Ricky Schroeder is out underneath the
bridge
calling for uh solidarity for Patriots
that are being purged from the military
and law enforcement because of their
patriotic views and the medical tyranny
of all the capitalist leaders taking
over the country and we must fight
you'll have to kill us
I mean unless it's raining if it's
raining it will postpone the whole you
know we'll postpone the whole you
killing us thing the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] just to get it you know
safely loaded into the bays and the
vehicles so that it's not destroyed by
the rain so the second lap a lot of
people I mean they all the supplies that
they grifted off these people
all the supplies and the money
that they grifted off these people to
have this event they don't want that to
get damaged and destroyed by the rain I
mean what would the grift be if we
didn't get all the supplies and stuff
that we tried to grift off these people
what would it be without that
if it got destroyed by a little bit of
water come on you can't have that we're
not fighting for Freedom here we're
fighting for the grift people turned and
started heading back towards Hagerstown
Speedway and that's where they're going
to be tonight and we're gonna
keep you guys updated because tomorrow
there are some leaders meeting on
Capitol Hill with politicians to discuss
some of their get the [ __ ] out of here
Ron says I would like to nominate the
right side broadcasting for an enemy of
their riveting three hour and seven
minutes coverage of traffic and DC
Beltway today
commentary here really just brings it
all together
they literally showed
on their right wing channels
the the Convoy the traffic Convoy which
you can see I mean it's it's a busy
highway
like
there's traffic on it all the time it
isn't like this is an empty [ __ ] road
and then all of a sudden because there's
a convoy there was a bunch of people on
the road there's always people on this
Beltway
I mean what what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
and Ricky Schroeder is giving giving uh
his two cents under a bridge somewhere
out west
uh buy a campfire
I don't know if he lives on a campground
in Utah or Colorado I don't know
I don't know I don't know what what is
going on with Ricky Schroeder but what I
do know is whatever's going on with
Ricky Schroeder just because he's he was
in Silver Spoons
and he was he's a he's a quote unquote
you know f-less celebrity
for [ __ ] off f for [ __ ] off by the way
just because he's an f-less celebrity
doesn't mean this delusion isn't the
same delusion that your family members
are falling for your co-workers are
falling for
this Q Anon Facebook Ivermectin Kate
covid Theater [ __ ] we've seen Ron
DeSantis
uh not just fall for it but perpetuate
it down in Florida when he had his props
the students behind him and they had
their mask on
and he comes in he took her [ __ ] mask
off
take her mask off
turn your mask off
because I don't want covet theater and
then he comes in like a day after and he
goes into a meeting he's got a [ __ ]
mask on
like that's the kova theater when you're
paying attention to what other people
are doing
really stupid okay
let's see what else do we have of course
I posted some videos of me being Lego
Batman oh yes I want to show some video
here this is one um that I posted on
Tick Tock too dude this is of uh
protesters in Russia now this is in St
Petersburg and apparently this is you
see that police officer here in the
video
has what appears to be someone who is a
civilian on the ground with their billy
club
um it looks like they're detaining them
and but the the the people posting these
videos say that these are protesters
fighting back against the Russian police
it is take a look here
there they fight off that police officer
and there's another police officer that
comes in
and he's being fought by these people
[Applause]
so it's not just brave people in Ukraine
that are are dissidents against Vladimir
Putin it's also his own people in Russia
um that are dissidents against him
this is a a report
um some people I posted this on Tick
Tock as well this is a report from James
Longman
from ABC News uh he's giving you a sense
uh in Moscow of what is happening now
let's let's listen here
Central Moscow here outside the bullshoi
and I just want to show you the sheer
amount of force that's been put out onto
the streets there are Riot police
military police
local Moscow police absolutely
everywhere I mean look at this column
that's coming past me here
now a lot of people were saying when I
post this because I said it was getting
heated in Russia they're like oh well
that just looks like a normal normal day
in America
that just looks like a normal day in
America
well they didn't listen to the whole
[ __ ] video obviously
and the reason why is because what he
says at the end
of why these Russian forces these
military forces are in Moscow in the
first place listen to why they're there
this is super [ __ ] important
and all around us are on the trucks I
mean this is the Pavilion in front of
the bullshoi obviously a huge symbol of
Russia's extraordinary
history and culture and this is
symbol of modern Russia I think
and what's also extraordinary is that
all around me here there's more people
being arrested taking off their trucks
all around me here are these huge groups
of people mostly young people
who are just walking
they're just circulating in this Square
so that's that's the reason why they
call them that those military columns
there
because people are walking
people are walking
okay that is what Vladimir Putin is
scared of just people being present and
walking
now
in this country we would say well that's
not that's not much of a protest maybe
maybe we would or maybe we wouldn't call
in forces to break that kind of a
protest up
in Russia that type of a protest out in
broad daylight that's [ __ ] Really
Brave
that's really brave because just walking
in an area and being present in an area
for the reason why they think you're
present in there in an area is is
endangering your safety and your life
and Russia they could see you as a
dissident and I'm going to show you a
video here soon
and shows you what they will do if they
think you are a dissident they're not
doing anything they're not shouting
they're not screaming
but they just want to make themselves
known
and the only way I can really describe
it is it's almost like
these are Shoals of fish
and these are sharks
and they're just darting around one
another
there are a lot of young people out here
as well and you just get the sense that
they're not here it's not a mistake that
they've come out
it's almost virtually impossible
to protest in this city now
but you see what he's saying is it's
impossible to protest so their protest
just has to be present that's their
protest just to be present
imagine in this country if the the the
largest form of protest that you could
do is just to be present
all you [ __ ] Freedom Fighters out
there
you con Boyers
do you have any idea what would happen
to you [ __ ] in Putin's Russia
if you [ __ ] blocked highways if you
were [ __ ] threatening to shut down
economies
with your trucks they Not only would
seize your trucks they would seize your
other property they would seize your
[ __ ] families because your dissidents
that's not what happened
I mean what happened was is you [ __ ]
bunch of whiny ass little [ __ ] had
your little Convoy and got scared Away
by rain
but in Russia in Moscow
the largest form of protest right now
that is anywhere near safe is to just be
present and you dumb [ __ ] think
you want Putin to rule or anyone Trump
to rule America like Russia
you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
it's not because
that there's forces there and arresting
people because I'm going to show you
another video
that Longman posted here
in the same time period from his same
little outing
and a lot of people said he should be
safe which he he's not safe either just
reporting some of this and then the next
video you'll see that let's go to that
uh let me give him credit here
I do appreciate him posting this stuff
from Moscow because
um he even says in some of his posts
that their social media is still working
and as long as it's still working he's
still going to report now this is a
video from his same outing he said feels
like police have gotten wise to the
silent protest and they've closed in so
this is after he did the first video but
listen to what he says here what he says
is very important about the mood and
what is happening and then you can watch
around him as it happens
situation feels like it's getting a bit
more tense now
um that just people are actually just
being arrested taken off the streets you
see behind him there's police force
behind him which is a little bit of a
different police force than what we saw
in the video before
so it's not just one police force that's
out and about to try to rest these
dissonants and it feels like the police
have just got one now here are the
people behind him that were before
lies to this tactic of the protesters
just want to play around and around and
so there are loads more now who've just
come down to basically so here's more uh
uh officers military and they're
blocking the crosswalk
right you see this column here this wall
they're blocking the crosswalk because
they don't want people to cross that
road
block the crosswalk because they don't
want them over here in this area
if you go back
and if you're not watching if you're
listening uh the area that he was
pointing to earlier and pointing out
that's part of Russian history they do
not want those people over there present
as to look like a protest
the reason why they don't want crowds of
people
Gathering up in these certain areas
regardless of the reason why they're
there is because it may be construed as
a protest against the invasion of
Ukraine
um
they want to be here and we have to be
careful what we say because there are
certain laws now that make it illegal
for us to use certain words so all I can
tell you is that there are people here
in Central Moscow this man now behind me
here we go do you see behind him here
the officers are going to arrest someone
being arrested there he's yeah
are upset the situation
happening in Ukraine
now as soon as he says Ukraine and he
sees recordings watch this person
walking right here the third officer the
last officer in line this is when he
says Ukraine right there watch this
officer watch his head snap back boom
ah he heard the word Ukraine
now let's listen to this video
in its entirety situation feels like
it's getting a bit more tense now
um that just people are actually just
being arrested taken off the streets and
it feels like the police have just got
wise to this tactic of the protesters
just walking around and around and so
there are loads more now who've just
come down to basically block the
crosswalk
but a lot of these young people just
feel they want to be here and we have to
be careful what we say because there are
certain laws now that make it
illegal for us to use certain words so
all I can tell you is that there are
people here in Central Moscow this man
now behind me also being arrested
here in Central Moscow who
are upset the situation
happening in Ukraine
a lot of these young people just want to
be here want to be want to be here and
we have to be careful what we say
because there are certain laws now that
make it illegal for us to use certain
words and by we he means journalists
that's what he means there that's what
that's what he's saying
when he's saying there's certain laws
now
where we have to be careful what we say
because we can't say what we want to say
or certain words
they're banning journalists from saying
certain words
all you Freedom trucker Trump humping
[ __ ] out there
who think Putin is some kind of big
tough guy and he's fighting fascism you
don't know what fascism is
you have no [ __ ] clue and I said this
last week you [ __ ] wouldn't
last two goddamn seconds two [ __ ]
seconds in Putin's Russia not two
seconds
[ __ ] idiots
thank you James for your reporting I
hope you stay safe there uh while you're
reporting there's one other video that I
want to show and I think I've got it
here
um before we go to the trendy Trends
we're uh 12 minutes into the second hour
and we're still on the timeline but here
is a video and I posted this on um
yeah uh and let me get the sound correct
here
I'm just going to mute the sound because
there's not a lot of sound if you if
you're not um watching if you're just
listening I'll try to describe this to
you I posted this video on Tick Tock 2
what this video shows is police forces
in Moscow stopping young people and
searching their phones
searching their phones
okay
yeah they're on the sidewalk and these
police forces are searching through
their phones to make sure they're not
dissidents now
when I posted this a bunch of pro-putin
GQ Piers a bunch of [ __ ] fascists
were like oh well this is the same thing
as Democrats requiring a vaccine
passport no it's not
no it's not that is not a thing these
people are not choosing
to have their phones searched or not
that's not what they're choosing
they're being forced to have their phone
searched to make sure they're not
dissidents
and if they are dissidents there will be
punishment to be a dissident and if you
do not comply with their search you will
be punished just because you chose
not to get vaccinated and knowing that
you didn't get vaccinated that's the
choices you made that you would lose
your job or you wouldn't be able to go
inside a certain restaurant or something
like that that that's not that's not
this type of fascism
that's not fascism at all that's you
choosing something making a choice and
living with the consequences
that's what this is
okay let's go to the Tweety tweets and
the trendy trends
let's see what's still trending uh San
uh Mourinho is trending a Russian
government has approved a list of
countries
uh
uh who have been unfriendly to Russia
according to CNN report following a
statement
Uh Russian state-owned domestic news
agency the Kremlin has approved a list
of countries who have been unfriendly to
Russia
they include Australia UK EU countries
Iceland Canada
electronstein Monaco New Zealand Norway
Korea
Santa San Marino Singapore USA Taiwan
Ukraine
and there there's a list of other
switzerlands I'm not sure
um
uh Palmer report says Russia is now
trying to Feud with tiny nation of San
Marino
when it doesn't work they'll try Dan
Marino I guess that's why why San Marino
is is um is trending
I mean the reason why is
is uh it's a very small country I'm not
sure where San Marino is
I'm not really sure
um never heard of it to be honest with
you
maybe that's why he's picking on it
number five Bill Barr gave an interview
on today with Savannah Guthrie
about his book that he's trying to Hawk
he's trying to sell you know what's
funny about billboard
is
all of all of us who are anti-trump
anti-fascist uh never Trump
uh never fascist type folks
pro-democracy type folks
whether you're a republican Democrat
independent
if you're pro-democracy you are not on
the side of billboard
billboard is a fascist he's a fat slob
and he is only in the self-interest of
himself and he has made that very clear
not just with this book but evidence
uh throughout the decades Bill Barr is a
selfish piece of fascist [ __ ]
now
Bill Barr thinks he I don't know what he
thinks if he's gonna win over people or
not but he lost us a long time ago us
being pro-democracy folks
and uh with this book
he's losing he's losing the trumpers by
the pound
um and I'm not sure what Bill Barr's
play is here I don't know now let's see
what Mayo has to say reminder
let's get the zoom to work correctly
reminder Bill Barr didn't say [ __ ] about
Trump's treason until he was done with
his stupid book
that's right
um the other crazy part about the bill
Barr thing
see if we can find it here
um I believe
yeah here it is to Today's Show Daniel
Goldman has it wait Did didn't he say
that Trump is unfit to be president and
the Republican party needs to break away
from him yeah he did say that
bar is so deceitful and he can't even
keep up his own story his own story
straight on today Savannah Guthrie the
former A.G William Barr says he'd still
vote for Trump in 2024.
what is this [ __ ] sycophantry
I know what it is Putin's Putin's still
alive and well
as long as Putin's still alive and well
there's probably still dirt on the son
of a [ __ ] I'm just saying
minus touch says Bill Barr shouldn't be
on TV he should be in prison I'm not
going to disagree with that
I'm not going to disagree with that
maybe that's why he would vote for Trump
in 2024. you know he's that [ __ ]
pardon
oh he needs a pardon that's probably why
okay let's see what else do we have are
we are 18 minutes into the second hour
let's take a quick break
my voice is struggling again let's take
a quick break we'll be right back right
after this
[Music]
we'll be right back
mark
Atkins
Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with Biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face well now you
don't have to be introducing the droop
with our patented droop technology every
mask is uniquely molded to not fit your
face just send us a selfie and we'll
have one of our droopers mold the mask
for you elastic free thanks to the truth
I don't even need to pull my mask down
anymore it just sags that way the group
lets you customize from a selection of
pre-war masks lipstick stains included
make sure to order your Drew today Drew
be the spread you want to see in the
world
catch Tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
Roundup at twitch.tv slash the Tony
Michaels we're back to the king of
Brilliance this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the shitless
Roundup
I found a couple clips
a bill Barr that I think we'll watch
from Savannah Guthrie's interview today
and maybe I'll talk about it maybe I've
already said it
but we are going to play a couple clips
from this interview I think it is
worthwhile dear to hear what this slug
has to say and we even know what
treasonous [ __ ] he has so let's make it
full screen
and let's go to Savannah and Bill Barr
having told the president it's BS why
didn't you say more right than and there
to the American people about it
well I I did as a member of the cabinet
uh say that to the press and that was
invoked all the way across the country
that I was taking that position and then
on the press conference on the 22nd of
December my last full day at the
department I held a press conference and
I reiterated it you said there's no
evidence of widespread fraud you didn't
say I think the president is dangerous
in fact in your resignation letter you
wrote I appreciate the opportunity to
update you this afternoon on the
Department's review of voter fraud
allegations now here you know the claims
are BS your words not mine why wouldn't
you have said something how do you write
a letter like that that leaves the
impression that there might be something
there well as you remember there was
basically an allegation du jour I mean
it was like playing whack-a-mole and you
know there there was uh there were
questions being raised yeah but does
that letter really reflect the spirit of
what you knew to be true it's dangerous
and it's BS well I didn't say he was I
said he was acting in a dangerous way
because he what you know he was not
listening to advice from his advisors
and in the past you could keep things on
track and now I felt he was sort of off
the rails yeah and you write in this
letter this resignation letter I am
proud to have played a role in your many
successes you go on to say your record
is all the more historic because you
accomplished it in the face of
Relentless implacable resistance even if
you felt that way this is somebody you
told Mike Pompeo he's dangerous you say
in your book you were worried about the
peaceful transition of power you even
had National Security concerns that you
voice in your book none of this is
present in this resignation letter
didn't the American people deserve to
know what you knew
well I you know I think on December 14th
that's when the State Certified the vote
and then and that's the day I tendered
my resignation the elect he tendered his
resignation when he thought that he
would be implicated in federal crimes
let's not beat around the bush
that's why he did that
that's why he thought he would be
committing federal crimes
so that's when he tendered his
resignation okay let's go back to the
trendy Trends and the Tweety tweets here
uh Bill Cosby is trending so we have we
have Bill Barr that's scumbag training
we have another bill that is a scumbag
trending
um Bloomberg reports knew the Supreme
Court has refused to reinstate Bill
Cosby's conviction for sexually
assaulting a Temple University employee
in 2004.
um so this is one reason why I'd like to
get Pope on maybe I'll see if I can um
you pop on sometime this week to give us
the reason why
they have refused to reinstate Bill
Cosby's conviction and explain that to
us ma'am I'd really like to know that as
you guys know there was a prosecutor
made a deal in public they said
something in the microphone that's what
overturned Bill Cosby's conviction which
is all [ __ ] BS to me I think that's
uh flimsy at best
so let's read uh if we have some other
news on this
um
um which it just means that he'll remain
in place AJ has AJ plus here is the
Supreme Court declined to hear their
request to reinstate Bill Cosby's sexual
assault conviction Cosby was freed last
year after court revoked his sentence on
a technicality because a D.A promised
not to prosecute him in 2005. 60 plus
women have accused Cosby of sexual abuse
again
um there was apparently a a private deal
made and then something said in public
um that caused the conviction to be
overturned so maybe maybe I'll I'll you
guys you guys like to have a popoc
breakdown of this now I know he'll
probably do it on legal AF this weekend
haven't been myself as well probably go
through that but it'd be nice to get a
little a little nugget of of why why
they rejected to hear this case
um or what his opinion on that is okay
let's go to do Mark Levin
for 25 minutes into the second hour
thank you
um markleman
is an idiot
um he's a he's a worthless sack of [ __ ]
I said again this morning to remind you
Mark Levin is trash good morning
uh Mark govin is a is a talk show radio
host he's a he's an attorney and he's an
author he writes [ __ ] books of course
um he's got a Fox News show now
uh so I'll give you a little background
I used to listen
I used to listen to Mark Levin
years ago a little bit not a lot but a
little bit
it's only so much you can stand to this
[ __ ] but I did listen to him to see what
the other side would say and you know I
did that a lot with Rush Limbaugh and
even Sean Hannity on their radio shows
as I was driving around I listened to
these pukes now I'd be yelling into the
[ __ ] radio the entire time because
I'm diametrically opposed to almost
every single [ __ ] thing these
scumbags say now having said that though
when Rush Limbaugh and Sean Hannity were
Trump sycophants they were fawning over
Trump
when he first started a run in 2016.
right got it they were fawning over him
the reason why his ratings and we now
know that Sean handed he may or may not
have Russian connections maybe the
reason why Sean Hannity had to you know
put his Cheeto desk knee pads on
and service
Grandpa Poopypants to Cheeto dust
mobster
but Mark Levin was not that way
Mark Levin was anti-trump
he was a never Trumper in the beginning
in 2016. you back and listen to his
shows
he would he would call him dumb stupid a
doofus
he doesn't know what he's doing he
wouldn't know how to run a country
he would have no idea to put how to put
together a coalition
of any people that were smart he's not a
conservative
on and on and on Mark Levin went about
about Donald Trump
hated him still hates him really
honestly he never really did the reason
why they hate Donald Trump
isn't because of his
sorry we had a bit of technical
difficulty there can you still hear me
are we still there
I think I think we're still here I think
everyone can hear me maybe yes we had
some technical difficulties I'm not sure
what happened but we are still
broadcasting we are still here let me
see if I can share my screen again
there we go you're talking about Mark
Levin
here he is sorry about that but Mark
Levin wasn't never Trumper
he was a never Trumper
so
it really is kind of You Know Rich that
this guy goes on Fox News and sycophants
for Maga and they all believe it they're
all in for the grift rather it be the
Mark Levin Griff the Sean Hannity Griff
the old Rush Limbaugh grift the Trump
grift the Convoy grift
whatever grifted it may be the America
First Nazi grift
the CPAC grift whatever grip that may be
that they are all in
and the grifters are still grifting
okay let's go back to the training
Trends and the Tweety tweets here
[Music]
Venezuela
is um
in the news let's see what what the
official report from Venezuela senior
U.S officials traveled to Venezuela on
Saturday to discuss potential easing
sanctions on the country's oil industry
in the apparent bid to isolate Russia
from its uh remaining allies according
to reports so it looks like they're
trying to free up oil from Venezuela to
come here
as to pressure Russia because here's the
thing if Russia can't sell oil they
can't make money
if they can't export it yeah they they
just sitting on a bunch of oil wells
that aren't making them any money
and that's good news now in this country
we are seeing gas prices go up because
of this
and it is a thing that's going to have
to happen that we have to do workarounds
and do these deals and uh
un undo our excuse me release
Reserves
which I really I really honestly I don't
think that we should do the reserve
thing I mean very rarely in this country
in the last half a century
have a lot of people had to sacrifice I
mean back during Second World War there
were people giving up their [ __ ] pots
and pans for the Steal
giving up giving up essential equipment
that they needed
because they had to
it's really crazy and ridiculous that
people aren't willing to sacrifice a
little bit now the president United
States and United States government is
doing everything they can to make sure
the gas prices don't Skyrocket
and turn our economy you know into a
swirling free-fall which I don't think
it will we have consumer confidence
uh people there's a big demand
for especially for labor which only
means because there's a demand for labor
means that there's consumer confidence
we have unemployment down to 3.8 percent
creating creating almost 700 000 jobs
just in the month of February
and and almost 500 000 jobs in the month
of January
which is drawing unemployment down to
levels of where it was pre-pandemic
which is good news for the for Americans
meaning that there's demand now we're
not all the way there of course with the
economy
and we're not all the way there with the
middle class we still have Republicans
in charge of big swaths of the country
state governments and even in like the
United States Senate where we can't get
stuff done for the American people you
know pro-democracy type [ __ ]
where it would give relief
to the American families for what they
want to call inflation ah you're taking
our gas away well Republican Senators
wouldn't advance to build back better
act as I call it here the Big Bird bill
which would extend inflation protection
for families that have children
in the way of the child tax credit
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
bitching about something that you you
aren't bitching in the right direction
you're bitching at democrats for the gas
prices being high and inflation when
Democrats are the only ones that are
delivering on inflation protection and
have delivered on inflation protection
damn [ __ ] uh Montel is training
at number 22 we're 32 minutes into the
hour
actor and former television host Montel
Williams calls Florida Surgeon General a
circus clown
see if we got this um
on tape
is there a
is there a clip of this happening or is
this just him saying it in an article
I'd love to hear it out loud
that's what I love
um as you know the Surgeon General of of
Florida is a sycophant some of you are
in Florida in the audience and know that
the Surgeon General there is a
he is a clown he's a DeSantis clown
and Trump is probably jealous
that Ron DeSantis has a has a sycophant
in the office to lie to the Floridians
actually we've seen that this weekend I
guess he said something about the
grandpa Poopypants the cheetah does
monster
their orange Mussolini Jesus you know
Trump
he said something about being jealous he
was big jelly
I have Kim Jong-un of how his his people
act around him
he wants to be a dictator
and I don't know how these people don't
see when he's fawning over Kim Jong-un
president XI of China
and Vladimir Putin
how don't these people see that this guy
wants to be a dictator a murderous
dictator
how don't you see that and you might be
the first to go
you people clogging up the highways with
your with your rained out Convoy okay uh
Alexander vinman is trending
as well retired lieutenant colonel
Alexander vinman a key witness in the
former president Trump's first
impeachment hearing responds to Marjorie
Taylor Green's comment about Ukraine
saying the GOP undermine U.S efforts
did a war occupied Democrats has the
headline here breaking Alexander vinman
rips Marjorie Taylor green for blaming
Russia's invasion of Ukraine on Biden
accuses her of having blood on your
hands for cheering Putin to invade and
undermining U.S efforts to stop Putin's
War
uh let's see if we can find these
some of these statements did he tweet
this or did he write this in an op-ed
um
looks like he wrote an op-ed and this is
Alexander vinman's tweet Alexander
vinman says it's kind of weird
that he's
using third person here you know
whatever Alexander benman says Ron
Johnson's a huge disappointment on
Ukraine
Johnson is scurried back to his comfort
zone which is how a political creature
and political animal that saw his
political survival to Pander to Donald
Trump well I mean this is not a big
surprise that Ron Johnson is a gutless
coward
um he went he went over and had his
fourth of July barbecue with Vladimir
Putin
um let's see is there let's see if
there's
was this like a Twitter battle or is it
just something that he responded to in
this article
is that I don't know do you why why do
they let okay outspoken's here says mate
Marjorie Taylor green attacks Lieutenant
Colonel Alexander vidman using Russian
propaganda
we must send flowers to Congress so
she's she's outspoken here is advocating
for Marjorie Taylor Green's opponent in
Georgia
um
MJ said there's a there's a thread okay
yeah send me the thread mg send me the
thread
in uh DM and I'll bring it up here
um oh here it is am I think this is the
thread I think this is the thread
here's the oh hoof foot green
is responding to
Alexander vinman
uh nope that's because you and your pro
uh let's go back
okay
uh tragically people are dying because
of Biden's poor decision making uh
leading up to Putin declaring war in
Ukraine Biden's weakness and failure as
a leader not only has put America last
but is a danger to the entire world
nope it's because you and your pro Putin
party encouraged Putin to invade by
cheerleading him that's right
well they gave they may you know they
gave the Putin the propaganda to feed to
his people that the U.S was behind his
invasion of Ukraine through the words of
Tucker Carlson and the former Secretary
of State and CIA director Mike Pompeo
pumping that propaganda into into
[ __ ] Russia
to justify why the American why the
Americans were for him invading worse
yet you undermine POTUS efforts to
signal
um I'm punishing cost
you undermine U.S efforts to deter the
war
you have blood on your hands the America
people will not forget
okay let's uh let's go to here and let's
give
her you sucks credit because that's
tweet definitely sucks yes I want to
tweet it
[ __ ] Marjorie Taylor green I you know
she got suspended but she's not really
suspended right
you notice that
she she goes on she goes on all these
[ __ ] right-wing shows and brags about
how she got suspended from Twitter and
she's still Tweeting like I can't tweet
but you're tweeting [ __ ]
either either be suspended or don't if
you don't like Twitter fine whatever
[ __ ] you don't tweet from your [ __ ]
official account
if you don't like it zip it [ __ ]
um vinman here and let's give him credit
and then let's go back to
um marjories here this clown wants to
drag Americans into war with Russia
with his big tough tweets and his Zoom
interviews on CNN
you mean like your big tough tweets
what are you talking about whenever you
[ __ ] sacrificed anything for for a
war anywhere
the whole foot go ahead and go fight
yourself since you're from Ukraine
what does that mean
go back to Ukraine is that what she's
telling
the the lieutenant colonel
who served on the National Security
Council
and was and honored his oath
get the [ __ ] out of here wouldn't you
wouldn't know what honor was
[ __ ] hit you on your goddamn [ __ ]
forehead
you are clueless about Americans being
fed up with sending our sons and
daughters to die on born land what are
you talking about this is exactly what
Biden is saying
exactly what he's saying Biden has said
over and over again I am not sending
American troops to die
in this battle
between Putin and Ukraine we will stand
with the Ukrainian people we are with
Ukrainian people but we will not put
troops on the ground because I will not
have our sons and daughters die in
foreign lands
really [ __ ] delusional [ __ ]
um let's see let's see did he respond to
this quote there's gotta be
gotta be gotta be I'm gonna go to his
feed here your Tweet sucks by the way
yep trunt
I'm sorry I can't help but use the words
people may not want me to use those
words about her but I I'm sorry I just I
I can't [ __ ] do it
um
it is ridiculous okay let's go
down let's see
I can find his response here
um
to that last tweet
now well here's Adam kinzinger's
response to that tweet that we just seen
Marjorie Taylor green is intensively
pro-putin this tweet even has tenses of
putinism in it it is putinism she blames
Biden for not being tough and then an
angry puts out a tweet that makes Putin
smile
never say what you'll never do Margie
Tater green and enable the Vladimir
MTG would never fight for anything
that's not self
and I'm not going to retweet this and
thanks for your Tweet uh Anna bikinis
King singer
mature I don't know I don't know if this
helps or hurts uh vinman retweeted this
I don't know
I think you could say much stronger
things here Adam than kind of the word
salad that you put together but whatever
and let's see if we can find uh benman's
response to the clown tweet
um maybe maybe maybe not I don't think I
don't think we're gonna see I don't know
that he has a response to that yet
I don't see it
if it is I don't see it
but I do see something here that I'd
like to show while we're here
on his thread
I don't know we're on a thread why not
has to do with Ukraine it's heartwarming
um this person has retweeted the Let It
Go
video
let's get 7.6 million views
uh MJ says she tagged me then okay let's
watch this video and I'll pull up that
tag and this is a heartwarming video
this is in a shelter bomb shelter in
Ukraine a little girl decides to
entertain all the folks
inside the bunker let's listen yeah
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's a good food
a little bit of Hope
and a little bit of human but bigger
than any heart
that we've seen in a while
um what a wonderful wonderful
video
and it is good to see
that folks still can find
hope
even in the words
of a song from this
little Ukrainian
girl
um kind of breaks me up and the reason
why is because
this little girl is probably about the
same age as My Little Girl
and I can't imagine living in a
democracy where you'd have to hide in a
bunker
and find Hope
in a Disney song
because a murderous dictator
was trying to kill you
so you wouldn't
sing to people
in your country
and
it's very very very
sad
that the Ukrainian people have the
democracy is imperfect as it is
as imperfect as it is
um it is uh
it is democracy and we should fight for
it
and thank you for the song I don't know
her name I wonder if we will ever find
her name but whoever she is thank you
thank you for your song and thank you
for your voice okay
let's try to go back to the trendy
Trends and Tweety tweets here as we um
fight through the emotion there
what a fantastic what a fantastic video
uh to give hope to the not only
Ukrainian people but pro-democracy
people
all around the world
okay uh let's see what else did we have
on the docket today I don't want to miss
anything I I had some stuff I wanted to
talk about there was a lot of stuff over
the weekend
um let's see
um everyone says Encore they want to
play it again maybe maybe before we
leave today we'll play that song one
more time or 46 minutes into the hour
so maybe here in about 10 minutes before
we leave we'll play that song again I
want to see if there's anything else I
missed here
[Music]
we had
Bill Cosby Bill Barr
excuse me the hashtag let free Florida
say gay
was trending earlier let's go see if we
can find
that
I would like to uh
possibly
see if there's video of that
of course there is
um here's um
Santiago mayor um Rhonda Santos and his
fascist goons and the state legislator
thought they could silence gen Z so as
gen Z paid them a visit so apparently
people are showing up
at the Florida Capitol
to stand in
solidarity with
people the lgbtq plus Community
where Florida is trying to pass a don't
say gay bill
of course
um Florida does their version of hatred
and fascism especially against the
others the lgbtq community and Texas is
trying to do the same thing
with their anti-trans bill trans
children they're trying to they're
trying to demonize and ostracize
children
um that's what the gqp does because
they're fascists because that's what
fascists do let's see if there's video
of these students or these young people
I'm protesting here's another picture
from Thomas Kennedy students and allies
are gathered outside the chambers of the
Florida legislator to protests that
don't say gay bill so there's some more
imagery of it if you'd like to see it it
looks like more and more people are
gathering this was posted
about two hours ago let's see if we can
find oh dang it
like to see if there's some video let's
go to videos
um
it doesn't look like there's any video
coming out of the capital yet under the
let free Florida say gay
um
see if we can
find some video under a different
search here
I want to find some video of the
students here we go
this is from March 4th
um it's it's George Sakai says I'm
incredibly inspired by the activism of
Florida students raising their voices
shouting say gay so let's watch this and
then we'll see if we can find video from
the
uh from the
wait a second protest today
we say again
sorry I'm not reading and I'm searching
for another video from today
and I am gay
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
do the good work and keep staying gay
[Applause]
of course a lot of this is in protest of
of someone just saying
um gay here is a scene that I found a
video from today the Florida Senate
Democrats posted this we've got one
thing to say our GOP colleagues we got
one same thing to say to him this is
video from inside
um the capital so we'll watch this
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
gay inside the capitol
um as they protest this bill
which is good to see everyone should
say gay in Florida everywhere grocery
store your church just say gay just say
it over and over again
because Republicans you know what's
funny
is these are the same idiots that say oh
you can't cancel you can't cancel
can't cancel the Washington Redskins or
Aunt Jemima
you can't cancel Dr Seuss
or you can't you can't cancel an Eminem
you can't you can't cancel
Mr Potato Head because of words and here
they want to ban an entire word
this has always been their MO
there's always been it
ah let's see let's go back to the trendy
Trends and Tweety tweets here
um I I want to play that video one more
time or 52 minutes into the hour I think
that video is about two minutes long I
just want to make sure we didn't miss
anything
um we've got we we went to the
uh don't say gay protest which will
follow that hopefully we'll have more
news on that tomorrow how that turns out
um we did Alexander vinman
um Mark Levin Montel Venezuela we went
through the we went through the trendy
Twins and the Tweety tweets today even
though I spent a lot of time on the
timeline I I got my voice back today
it's not 100 as you can tell but we are
back we are back we got some big
announcements this week
um so stay tuned this week noon Eastern
11 Central
as always YouTube Twitter twitch uh go
ahead and subscribe to the YouTube
channel you're going to want to do that
you're definitely going to want to
subscribe to the YouTube channel so you
don't miss anything we're gonna try to
get together an interview that we uh we
did several weeks ago that we're going
to try to put together uh so we have
that ready for you this week we also we
also have a big interview that we're
recording on Friday we can't wait to
announce that after we have that
recorded we're going to I'm going to try
to get Pope on to give us some Lowdown
on some of the legal stuff happening I
also want to get you guys have seen we
had Dakota atoms on the estranged Sun of
Stuart Rhodes there's a lot of oath
keeper news we want to try to get Dakota
on this week sometime uh to try to see
what his take is on some of the news of
The Oath Keepers
um it's particularly Mr James who is a
private security apparently during
January 6th for Roger Stone uh as an
oath keeper who he was taking orders
from and what his purpose was he has
pled guilty to sedition this conspiracy
of which he's been charged so I think
maybe I think maybe that will um I think
maybe maybe that will be a thing that we
have uh get to code on this week uh we
also want to have Rachel bitkoffer back
this week I want to have her back so we
got a lot of stuff going on this week so
do not miss any episode this week noon
Eastern 11 Central if you do miss it
don't worry it's on all the directories
even the ones that are boycotted we're
on Apple Google Spotify you can find
them all there give us a five star
rating over there if you haven't already
even if you don't listen to them over
there go give us a five star review that
would help out a lot And subscribe to
the YouTube channel or go over to Twitch
some people are still watching on Twitch
you can watch all the episodes over
there on Twitch as well and on Twitter
on their Twitter feed
so stay tuned this week Newton Eastern
11 Central
if you want to support the podcast that
would be fantastic I know you guys like
you share you guys come and you chat I
love with you guys chat
um all you guys every single day here
live as we chat but also if you want to
support the podcast you can go to the
Tony michaels.com we have merch stores
there my merch store Gabe's merch store
if you want some Gabe merch
or if you want to give to the podcast
upgrade fund that would be fantastic
as we make some announcements we are
going to get some different softwares
which is going to cost us
um some subscription so we're we're
waiting on those announcements and
waiting on those things so if you'd like
to support the podcast and that way you
can just go to thetonymichaels.com
the link is in my bio
and you can either look at some merch
store and all the links are there all
the Social Links I'm on the
instagrammies and I've been tick-tocking
lately so don't don't forget to follow
me there
um let's play Let's play this um
this little sweet girl singing Let It Go
one more time before we leave let's let
her let's let her sing us out here
[Music]
if they choose
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
beautiful beautiful hope
from a beautiful beautiful little human
and I I hope I hope her and her family
stay safe in the bunker stay safe from
the
the murderous dictator who is Vladimir
Putin and the Russian army and hopefully
this conflict can come to an end soon
before we see more innocent people who
have to hide in bunkers away from the
danger who have to escape their country
away from their danger and be refugees
um
and I hope that all democracies around
the world will stand with Ukraine and
all pro-democracy people from around the
world will stand
with this little bitty perfect human
that has a great voice and not only
great voice but a very entertaining one
um she she's a star in my book
until tomorrow until tomorrow
thanks for joining us noon Eastern 11
Central YouTube Twitter twitch as always
every single weekday we'll see you
tomorrow Surf's Up [ __ ] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
's meal Barn hadass Beacon